it's the game of foot I believe it is
Sherlock is back with the six fetchers
now this is a show I haven't really
talked about before but it is one that
I've been watching since it first turned
up and I loved it I loved sure I mean
Iowa I've always liked Sherlock Holmes
from a young kid but I'm not a fan of
every iteration of Trellick Holmes I do
really like BBC's Sherlock though so
here's my chance to do a review of a
brand new Sherlock fairly soon after it
has aired now I'm gonna give you the
warning right now this will not be
spoiler free cuz a lot of stuff I really
want to talk about that would all be
considered spoilers so stick around to
see my face for the immediate impression
and after that maybe buzz off and see
the thing yourself unless you don't care
in which case stick around so what I
think about the six thatcher's I think
this is the first episode of Sherlock
that I can say flat-out I don't like
there have been some that I've liked
less than others there even room or some
that was like that was okay I don't need
to see that again like the Hound of the
Baskervilles kind of fell under that
category but I've never come away from
an episode going wow I kind of wish I
hadn't seen that but I did with this for
a number of reasons and they pretty much
all center around Watson and Mary but
we'll get back into that because I know
I'm going to get ranty once I start
talking about that so before I get into
full-on rant mode let's talk about what
was nice well
Benedict Cumberbatch has not lost a step
he's still great to show like he's
always great at Sherlock Martin Gaydos
as my cropped wonderfully slimy as he
always is and there are certain moments
that I do absolutely love like for
instance I love when Mary goes through
all this trouble all these random things
you know to try to avoid Sherlock and
then he's just there and he goes through
this whole ramble of how he could figure
out what she was gonna do and this is it
but that's really hard so I just put a
tracer in this in the memory stick that
was great and that was awesome and that
was Ben so there were moments like that
across the episode that were wonderful
but man okay so I've got I've got a lot
of issues with the whole Watson and Mary
thing almost everything they did with
that I don't like now part of it has to
do with timing
i I understand to a certain extent I
don't necessarily agree with but I do
understand the creators instinct that
once they tie down a character to a
marriage if it is a happy marriage that
it's going to be harder and harder to
excuse their going off and doing these
adventures anymore you get that all the
time it's why these sort of
relationships never last in anything
that is intended to be ongoing whether
it's Buffy or whether it's agents of
shield the one you know the hook-up can
happen but then it's just a matter of
time before the writers rip it apart
because they see it as being limiting
and they've done that here and I really
hate it and but here's the thing even if
I set aside the fact that I hate that
they were tearing them up and then
eventually killed Mary anyways even if I
set it aside that I hate the fact that
we're doing this immediately after the
previous series where they just got
married
couldn't we have at least one that
series where they're together and happy
and dealing with it before we tear
everything apart you know give us some
weight make it build a relationship that
we are going to be sorry it gets torn
apart instead they tear it apart almost
as soon as they put them together in the
first place and that undermines the
impact that you could have had doing
this even if I thought it was a good
idea in the first place which I don't
because if it was ever gonna be a
character who was like no fine go off
and do this it was gonna be married
seemed like she was built for that now I
haven't looked into this too deeply but
I do understand that there may be a meta
reason why this has happened which is
that Martin Freeman and Amanda Abbington
who play John and Mary Watson are an
actual couple in real life and they're
splitting up so if there was tension
between them in the marriage they may
have something seen that and she may
have requested to the writers guys
please write me out so I don't have to
keep doing this and I understand that
might be part of the reason we're in the
situation in the first place but it's
the end result I still don't like so
while maybe I couldn't understand why it
happened I still don't like it and all
of us even before they killed her which
that uh but I'll get to that moment in a
minute but all that you know here with
John with that woman on the bus I was
like oh come on
or Mary sort of young drugging sure like
and doing this runaway thing which was
very close to what went on with her like
in the episode where she and John got
mayor
so I'm going again like again
immediately and then with Oh God
the minute that woman pulled the trigger
even before when the slow-motion I
thought to myself oh don't oh don't it
no don't
Oh for the love and then she jumps in
front end it Oh God and I leave it I
honestly don't even really know how
emotional the goodbyes between John and
Mary was because I was sitting there the
whole time going for crying out loud why
did you do that just overall I thought
they undermined the relationship between
them too soon it had not been
well-established enough for that to have
any true emotional weight I think
killing her off was the cheap and lazy
way to go and it completely undermines
what happened at the end of the last
series and honestly almost everything
that happens here undermines what
happened at the end of that series with
shrug making a valid he's got to protect
them and then immediately look blows it
again him having to him failing at that
vow would it have more weight if he'd
been holding on to it for longer than
what a couple months and I understand
that in real time we've had about two
years I know it's been a long time for
us but it's been a very short time for
them and normally I'd be okay with the
story sort of coming in and you know we
had left where he had shot that guy he
was coming back and Moriarty's coming
back and that was obviously our big hook
in to this series and we all came in
going what's going on with that normally
I kind of be okay if they went in going
okay look that's gonna happen we're
gonna set it aside and tell you this
story normally I'm okay with that but
I'm not in this case for a couple of
reasons the first is is that there were
huge big massive implications for for
what went on and they just gotta go
happen for a lot of them and then what
is still hanging around they just said
we'll stick a pin in and come back in it
later and I'm not okay with that one
there's only three episodes in a series
when you're doing a 24 episode show or
even a 10 episodes show a short season
show that's fine I will allow you to set
the main story side to tell me
individual ones when you've only got
three you can't focus on the story you
set up for three freakin episodes you
got to drive a wedge between Watson and
Sherlock again just like you did at the
start of series 3 after shrew I keep
and it was brilliantly executed then and
now we're gonna get a watered-down
version of that with Mary's death like
this one if I didn't know that Toby
Jones was coming in at the Villa I might
give up I mean I would still watch these
things regardless but I wouldn't have a
lot of hope I do have a lot of hope
because I love Toby Jones that I loved
him in villain mode and the little
glimpses we've gotten he can be
wonderfully slimy and I'm hoping that a
strong villain will help this thing come
back because this this is the worst
Sherlock episode period this is it this
is just bad and I never thought I'd say
that about this show that's depressing
that's not a great way to start a new
year in my book so the sixth patchers
first episode of Sherlock series four
did you see it what were your thoughts
on it whatever they were drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it don't forget to like subscribe
hit that Bell so you get notifications
when I put new stuff up follow me on
Twitter I counsel with geeks check out
the council of geeks podcast available
on iTunes and stitcher run until next
time this council is adjourned